um okay I want to talk today about um
continue our discussion of oligopoly
last time we talked about
non-cooperative equilibria but we in the
start we said gee life would just be
better off everyone would just cooperate
and someone even asked me well why don't
they just cooperate so let's talk about
that let's talk about cartels what
happens when firms try to cooperate
achieve the cooperative equilibrium in
oligopolies now clearly this is gonna be
the best outcome so to fix examples
let's go back to our example of last
time American united recall last time we
said the demand was of the form 339
minus Q prices 339 minus Q and that the
marginal cost was 147 okay now we talked
about the fact that if American was a
monopoly in this market they would
simply solve the monopolist problem they
would set marginal revenue which is 339
minus 2q equal to marginal cost which is
147 and they would get that the optimal
Q would be 96 and then reading back off
the demand curve that in place imply an
optimal quantity of two hundred and
forty three dollars okay so that was
what we got last time
now imagine that Americans not a
monopoly but American United cooperate
what if they got to goodness said you
know what let's behave as if we're one
monopolist flying 96 flights and just
splitting them equally we'll do forty
eight you do 48 so let's cartelize let's
achieve the monopoly outcome and those
two share 5050 the fruits of that
outcome so in that case each firm would
fly 48 flights at a price of 243 dollars
okay and total profits in the market
each firm would then make profits of 48
times price minus average cost which is
marginal costs because it's flat times
to 43 minus 147 or so it's like I'm not
like you guys can do that my head
4608 per firm okay so each firm would
achieve profits of forty states take the
ninety six flights split them in half
and then achieved profits of 4608 now
what we can see is that these profits
are much higher than what they got in
the non cooperative equilibrium
remember the non-cooperative equilibrium
they were each doing sixty-four flights
at a price of the you chewing sixty-four
flights at a price of 211 we solved that
last time so what were their non
cooperative profits they're non
cooperative profits for each firm was 64
times the 211 they were charging minus
the 147 in marginal costs or their
former prophets were 4096 so their
profits used to be 4,000 ices when they
weren't cooperating they've gone up by
12.5 percent to 46 Oh eight by
cooperating so simply by getting
together saying don't be an [ __ ]
let's cooperate let's figure how to make
the most money getting together they
solve the prisoner's dilemma get to the
best outcome and make a lot more money
okay so the question is why don't they
always do this in oligopolistic markets
and fundamentally there's two reasons
now normal people you see when I'm done
normal people will teach them in a
different order than I will but let me
start with the two reasons in the
ordering Connors would teach them the
first reason why cartels don't form is
that they're fundamentally fundamentally
unstable cartels are fundamentally
unstable as long as firms are
self-interested each individual firm in
a cartel has an incentive to cheat and
that's because they essentially could
solve the monopoly problem of poisoning
by cheating let me explain how that
works this best sees through numbers
let's imagine that we start in this
cooperative equilibrium forty eight
flights each improv so 4608 and now
let's imagine in the middle that quietly
American increases its number of flights
from forty to fifty American says well I
know agreed forty eight but on the slime
and I fly two more flights and hope they
don't catch me okay well what's
Americans profits
well their quantity is 50 Q sub a is now
50 what's the price if they can do 50
flights what's the price yeah
I'm sorry it's 280 it's the price is
let's see we got that right go check my
notes no no if the price was 243 when
they're monopoly now they're doing two
more flights remember they're adding two
flights to the total there used to be
there used to be 96 flights now goes to
98 flights so price falls to 241 okay so
you were thinking about them as a loan
but remember there's still united doing
the flights - they're still doing 48
flights so there are 96 flights total
now it goes to 98 so the price falls to
241 okay
so what's their profits their profits
are now 50 times 241 - 147 or 4,700
their profits have gone up okay let me
back up and do it again because I went
fast okay they saving in two more
flights we have to respect to demand
curve so there could be two more flights
the price has to fall if the price falls
then the price has to fall 241 they now
make profits of 4700 okay well if United
is caught with their pants down and
continues to forty eight flights what is
United make well United still doing 48
flights so the profits have United are
48 times 241 - 147 or 45 12 so Americans
profits are up and United profits are
down through American cheating what
happened
how by cheating did they draw what's the
intuition of why them cheating drove
their profits up and is down and in fact
if you add these up lowered total
profits in the market what's going on
yeah
see my quantity you're lowering the
price that you can sell each unit for
but for American because they're
increasing the number of units they're
selling they still make a great profit
whereas United States and because each
unit be sold for less and again that's
that's almost right you got most of it
but there's one key wrinkle that's
important which is a monopolist would
have the same argument the the key thing
is why doesn't what stops the monopolist
from raising the price from where he is
yeah the poisoning effect but think
about the poisoning effect who's the
poisoning effect affect everyone in the
market everyone sees a lower price but
only American gets more flights so they
essentially get the benefit it's like
you said they get the benefit the extra
flights but only half the penalty of the
poison effect so for them it is optimal
to rich to lower the price and sell more
because they share the negative effect
the negative part with United but they
get all the positive part once again a
monopolist when you rip when you try to
sell more and lower the price there's a
positive approach to sell more units but
a negative part which is the poisoning
effect well here American gets all the
positive part only half the negative
part so they make money by cheating okay
well of course United knows this they
saw the place go down they know
Americans cheating
so United wants to cheat and the whole
thing breaks apart sort cartels are
unstable because by cheating you get all
the benefit but only part of the cost
and since so cheating is incentivized at
a cartel and therefore cartels will
break down they're not stable okay so
that's the primary reason economists say
we don't see cartels the other reason
people like to bring up is this little
thing they're illegal but you know we
don't let stuff like that bothers
economists but they are illegal that's
another reason why we don't see cartels
in the late 1800 cartels were quite
common in late 1800s big industries like
oil and railroad industries came to be
dominated by a few large firms and they
tried to become cartels but it kept
breaking down so its fatal eighteen
hundreds with oil company Standard Oil
and the big
companies they kept trying to have
cartels and a cape breaking down say
couples idea
they basically arm said look we can't
trust each other so we're gonna every
firm is gonna turn over all its
decisions to a common trust and there'll
be a trust that's got representatives
for every fern on the board but we will
publicly commit to what we're gonna
Bruce at what price and therefore we can
make sure there's no cheating so
essentially every firm still involved
they're all in this trust board but
they're making that decision in a in a
in a way that's at least public to them
not public to the public but public to
them so they can make sure they're not
cheating they form these trusts and
essentially Carter lies they made huge
profits and it worked
it's all the stability problem because
cheating could be observed more readily
now what a solved it very long we don't
know because the government the public
are pissed and the government came in
and passed what's called antitrust laws
and antitrust laws are laws which do not
permit the Cardinal is a ssin of India
of oligopolistic industries in this way
so let's talk about antitrust laws and
how they work or how they don't work I
want to do a couple examples what
examples the movie industry now the
movie distri you know is a classic
oligopolistic industry you know there's
a few players there's new players 8:24
is huge now what didn't exist 15 years
ago but by and large is sort of a few
players you've heard of which dominate
the industry
okay these and the way the industry
works is movie companies make and they
produce the movies and then sell them to
movie theaters that show the movies they
show a variety movies at any one time
well what happened was in the 30s and
40s
the production company started buying up
the movie theaters and what they do when
they bought the movie is a movie theater
we now own you and you will only show
our movies so I say the movie theater we
now own you you know movie theater on
the corner of you know Lincoln and
Kennedy streets and we're MGM and you
only show MGM movies and essentially
what that meant was essentially they
were taking over monopolizing a given
distribution network and they
essentially carved it up they agreed
okay you get these theaters we'll take
these theaters and it said
that was the way they formed their
cartel was through distribution and the
federal government jumped in and said
that that was an antitrust violation the
federal government sued and won and so
that industry that that um that was
broken up but did that mean that didn't
mean folks stopped trying to Carta lies
it just meant they stopped being so
obvious about it
so later moves to Carta lies were more
hidden so for example in the early 2000s
airline industries were in big trouble
because oil prices were going way up due
to the Iraq war and other factors oil
prices were going way up and the airline
industry was in trouble so in 2004
British Airlines and Virgin Atlantic had
secret talks about essentially carta
lies in the cross atlantic market from
the east coast to to london and what
they did is they said look if we sort of
obviously set our prices together people
are gonna notice so you do is instead is
we're gonna add fuel surcharges to the
bill we're gonna say oh gasket oils
getting more expensive your price
haven't changed but there's now a fuel
surcharge on your bill and that fuel
surcharge is going to be suddenly won't
pay attention just they won't notice
that we're rising it together and these
fuel surcharges rose quickly from ten
dollars to 120 dollars per flight and
essentially rose in lockstep they
essentially coordinated but tried to
hide it by making the coordination not
over the sticker price but over this
thing it's sort of the bottom of your
ticket which was the fuel surcharge so
this worked for a while but then what
happened well what happened with the
prisoner's dilemma was that lawyers for
lawyers for virgin airlines started
worrying they were to get busted and
they said well if we go to the feds
first and bust British Airlines
maybe we'll get a better deal so they
were essentially the prisoner that
ratted the Virgin Atlantic went was the
prisoner that ratted and the whole thing
broke down there were penalties more on
British Air Lines cos Virgin Atlantic
ratted on them but just like the
prisoner's dilemma breaks down it broke
down in reality and so that was
something not where the law really
worked but where the the cartel was
unstable
and the end result was Virgin Atlantic
paid no fees paid no penalty and British
Airlines paid more than five hundred
million dollars so British Airlines
coolly did not study the prisoners
dilemma
did not realize that they should have
gone first and ratting out Virgin Virgin
Atlantic now that said sometimes cartels
open operate openly in the public and
get away with it ok let's talk about
probably the biggest open cartel in
American perhaps in America today the
National Football League
ok the National Football League football
is the most popular sport in America the
most profitable sport in America there
are 32 teams and they're essentially 32
businesses whose job it is to produce
football wins okay now these businesses
have a huge incentive to collude with
their fellow business however because
because they can because of television
rights so the New York Giants of the New
York Jets competed over the television
rights for their area they would compete
away the profits that could be made by
getting a big contract if they collude
and say no you can only we will only
agree to a contract together they can
get a higher price for that contract
because it's either you give them the
contract you're out if they competed TV
covers for P because each other and
fight the price down okay
and in general access goes more than
this the league sells the rights to
televise games as a package so in fact
the National Football League literally
sells explicitly says we have a cartel
of 32 teams we are selling the monopoly
right to televise these games
somebody's got Sunday somebody's got
Thursday somebody's gots Monday night
etc but it's a monopoly product they're
selling now how did they get away with
that
well basically actually in 1957 they
were busted that's a long time ago it's
even before I was born that long ago
okay they were busted and the court
ruled that the NFL was violating
antitrust laws okay now that was fought
in 1957 that was 60 years ago the NFL
would still makes about 40 billion
dollars on his television contract what
happened
Congress just exempted them Congress
said well you know what we know they're
violent I trust but we're gonna pass a
law which exempts them from antitrust
law and let them do it
so proves basically that Americans like
football more than free markets and
basically we now have a Cardinal eyes
football industry that because Congress
basically exempt them from the laws
okay so those are some examples yeah
other sports teams
it is not add there are it's largely
true for other sports leaks it's largely
true the the some of the versions aren't
explicit football but it's largely true
for other sports leagues as well it's
simple I mean I don't know I don't know
that you have international antitrust
laws I'm not sure how that works with
international league it's a good
question um okay now another form of
cartels we talked about cartels and how
companies instead of to put them
together actually sometimes the federal
government can make a cartel yeah OPEC
so OPEC is as I mentioned the first
lecture a series of countries that get
together produce oil it's not working as
well as it was when I was a kid we're
really well because more countries a
more countries are cheating and more
countries there's more oil being found
outside OPEC but it still works it's
sort of a partially functioning cartel
as I think the way to think about it um
okay so let me um let me actually let me
go on and talk about lesson do one more
example about a time when a government
made a cartel here's a one more
interesting example so in the early
1980s before the early nineties the US
dominated the car production business
starting in the late 70s Japan started
making huge inroads into car production
and by the early 1980s we're in
recession and car manufacturers in the
u.s. are really pissed that Japan was
taking so much of our market and we'll
talk it a couple election about
international trade and all those set of
issues but put those issues aside right
now you just have this issue that car
manufacturers wanted to limit the amount
of Japanese cars come into America now
you guys have been reading in the paper
about international trade and why
economists typically don't like limiting
limiting international trade and Reagan
was you know a standard Republican part
of the party of free trade so Reagan
said well we're not gonna limit the cars
that Japan wants to send in but we're
gonna tell Japan if you guys were
willing to agree to a voluntary export
restraints
we wouldn't mind so what he said to
Japan
something called a voluntary export
constraint which basically said you we
will negotiate deal with you where you
will voluntarily agree
to reduce the number of cars you send to
America okay it's not a government
policies isn't big government this is
pride negotiations of private company
voluntary agreement okay Japanese to
this why yeah because because you need a
cartel yes the Japanese companies used
to have to compete with each other sell
the cars in America now it's like okay
you guys get together and limit how many
cars you send they're like great
you've given us an ability to form a
cartel by central telling us get
together and figure out how you gonna
sell as many cars to America so
essentially this voluntary export
strains essentially cartelized and no
company could cheat so if you had a
cartel any cup and tried to cheat they
couldn't sell the cars to you just
wouldn't let them come into the US so
essentially the u.s. provided them a
wave and forcing their cartel what
happened well um the average price of a
Japanese car in America went up by
$1,200 okay
u.s. Auto profits did go up but US
consumers lost out by way more than
producers gained and on that the
estimates are that US consumers about
three billion overall u.s. about three
billion dollars worse because of this
policy
it's just examples of how different way
different government policies can
interact with the cardinal's ation of
industries yeah company like price
matches isn't that sort of like making a
cartel like because that other company
would see it they're gonna price it
actually I wouldn't want to set a price
lower than that well it's a great
question and you're pointing out this is
not a solid line and in some sense the
question is if it's true that so for
many years tobacco industry worked this
way
there was one large player Philip Morris
Philip Morris would sort of raise the
price that ever would match now as long
as there's no evidence that they agreed
to do that that is not illegal if
there's evidence they agree to that's
illegal but as long as it's just like no
we're just this is the way it's going to
work then that's not illegal so
basically that's sort of an implicit
cartel now once again what's holding it
together nothing a company could cheat
and try to be
try to charge less but basically that
essentially they figured they're working
better as a cartel and essentially was
hard - there was no way to bust it yeah
I mean like if a company says to
consumers like if you can bring in a
lower price we'll sell it for that price
that's sort of a different I mean you
could imagine you would need every
company do that that would be a cartel
enforcing way if every company had that
deal in a market but one company of that
deal doesn't doesn't enforce the cartel
every company need to have that deal and
so the question is if every company if
every company on their own or gainfully
sited we're gonna have that deal that
would essentially be a way of trying to
bring in force the cartel but I think
that would be hard to say was an anti
truck wasn't antitrust violation it's
good good questions other questions okay
so now let's ask why do we care about
all this we care about all this because
it matters for ultimately what matters
to us in this class which is economic
welfare okay so now let's go to the
second thing I want to cover which is
comparing the equilibria we've now
covered three types of market structures
perfect competition Monopoly and
oligopoly now let's compare them and I
compare them in two ways quantity sold
and profits and profits profits per firm
profits earned per firm and we're gonna
stick with this United American market
okay we know if there's a monopoly if
this is a monopoly if they can car
perfectly cartelize then there'll be
ninety six flights total each one fly
forty eight flights and profits per firm
will be forty six owing and we solve
that already that's the cartel outcome
the non cooperative outcome which we'll
call the oligopoly outcome is they each
sell sixty four flights we saw that last
time and as we saw here they each make
profits a fourth for no nine six what's
the competitive outcome in this market
what's the competitive outcome in this
market first of all what's the price
somebody raise their hand and tell me if
this is a perfectly competitive market
with the price beat and well and then
what would the quantity yeah price new
147 because a perfectly competitive
market price of marginal cost so profits
would be zero and quantity would be 339
minus 147 or 192 okay so here we have
for a given market a nice table which
lets us compare the three different
possible outcomes and what you see is
essentially the more you can monopolize
the higher your profits but the smaller
the market okay so basically three
lessons here first of all
generally speaking the oligopoly outcome
is somewhere between the monopoly and
perfectly competitive outcome where in
between take 1412 what 1412 was about is
how you figure out where in between this
outcome comes between these two it's all
about game theory okay so that's what's
exciting about game theory is this is a
wide range and game theory as it says
sophisticated tools that let us pin down
we're in this range companies will end
up in the realistic case point to is the
more you can monopolize the higher your
profits will be but let us come to
welfare now having computed SERP social
surplus here but here's the cheat I
don't really need to I don't need to
because essentially roughly speaking
social welfare is proportional to the
quantity sold in the Lord's we know that
in a perfectly competitive market this
is the welfare maximizing qualities 192
we know that there's a hundred ninety
two flights that maximize welfare cuz
that's the competitive outcome what
we're saying is the more all this
shouldn't be 64 128 that's my bet 64 we
know that as we monopolize the market
there are fewer and fewer flights
therefore we're creating a deadweight
loss essentially deadweight loss is
proportional actually it's sort of
exponentially proportional to the gap
between the quality sold and the
competitive quantity
welfare's maximize here by definition we
prove that so any reduction from that
means that increased deadweight lost so
the more you reduce quantity the more
you lower welfare so essentially as we
go down the down the column we lower
profits but raise social welfare yeah
yeah you know cartel / monopoly yes but
all the way to 96 you prosper beaten
would be twice that but the bottom line
is that essentially you've got you
you've got essentially more profits in
this market ok other questions about
that so the bottom line is the more
competitive the market the higher the
welfare but the lower the profits okay
so that's kind of our bottom line of how
we think about this questions about that
ok next thing I want to cover we've only
covered the case of two firms what if
there are many firms after all most
oligopoly markets are not just two firms
Karm are we talking about cars and movie
producing studios there are many firms
ok
well the cournot model is super hard to
do when there's more firms but there's
no reason you can't it's literally just
becomes three equations and three
unknowns or four equations and four
unknowns little as you can see you could
simply see as you take that model and
add more firms it just expands the state
space it becomes impossible to graph but
you could solve it eventually we've got
n equations in n unknowns the key bottom
line result is that as the core note as
the number of firms gets large they're
cournot equilibrium approaches the
competitive equilibrium that is
mathematically if you solve this you
don't have to solve this but the bottom
line condition is the mark-up that Ferns
earned is equal to minus 1 over N times
the elasticity and instead of a market
this is sort of in a symmetric cournot
market of the kind we've been working
with
the mark-up is one over the number of
firm sons the elasticity of x the
elasticity of demand so think about this
for a second imagine there is one firm
then this equation says the markup is
equal to minus one over the last two see
demand where have we seen that before
that's the monopoly condition that's the
monopoly markup condition so an N equals
1 this is an equation we've seen before
the monopoly markup condition when N
equals 2 the firms are making half as
much when a equals 3 a third it goes in
fact factor third etc what this says as
n approaches infinity we approach the
competitive outcome ok we'll never get
there but we're asymptoting towards the
competitive outcome which basically says
you know it's sort of like my point
about catastro markets you get a market
that's sort of competitive enough you're
gonna shrink
you're gonna shrink the mark up as more
and more firms enter ok so that's sort
of a general condition that we could
derive that shows that um as more firms
as more firms are in then you get a
lower markup um now I wanna make there's
actually but this actually understates
the case for an important strategic
reason which is more firms lowers the
markup in a in a more firm lows of our
company cournot non-cooperative model
but more firms also makes a cooperative
model harder so this is for the non
cooperative model the non cooperative
model your profits follows they're more
firms but it also gets harder to
cooperate as they're more firms because
they're more people they're more people
you have to trust more people you have
to keep hold of it's a great example of
this actually for a long time
mercury just stuff we using thermometers
and such only was found in Italy in
Spain in the mines in Italy in Spain and
they had a cartel between the two
countries to sell mercury what happened
other countries discovered mercury and
they couldn't keep the cartel together
and the price of mercury fell a lot with
the question about OPEC similar thing
OPEC was much more successful in the
1970s when essentially the only source
of oil were basically these Arab nations
that form OPEC
what happened over time as you
discovered more oil around the world in
particular in Russia and in the US which
is sort of broken the power of this
cartel to a large extent so the reason
why a bigger market moves us towards the
competitive equilibrium is that it makes
it harder to maintain a cartel okay now
let's actually the other issue I want to
cover here is I want to talk about what
is what does all this teach us about a
key policy issue which is the issue of
mergers
what does everything we've learned here
tell us about thinking about mergers ok
we know about mergers happens all the
time two companies merge well it turns
out when companies merge and they're
large enough the federal government
regulates that the federal government
gets a vote on whether that merger is
going to be allowed to go forward either
the Department of Justice the Federal
Trade Commission depending on what kind
what industry it is so the federal
government has to decide how do you
evaluate whether two firms merging is a
good idea or not and essentially what it
comes down to is a simple trade off
economies of scale versus market power
the benefit of two firms merging these
economies of scale if two firms have
sort of redundant production processes
and they merge they can be more
efficient there can be positive
economies of scale for merging firms
okay so there's cost efficiencies
basically connie's of scale deliver cost
efficiencies on the other hand the more
firms merge the more this end goes down
and the more markets go up and the worse
it is for consumers so the trade-off is
do you want to reduce it's reducing n
worth it in terms of the kinds of scale
or in other words does the producer
efficiency go up enough to make up for
the potential loss to consumers of this
less competitive market okay
people understand that now interesting
case of this which has been got very big
implications for all of us in America is
hospital mergers during the decade of
the 2000s there was a rash of hospital
mergers
we're Hospital said look here's a
classic case recon as a scale because
hospitals have what's called a peak load
problem they have to have empty beds
hostels can't be full all the time
because there might be a car accident
and people need beds so by definition
it's inefficient for hospitals to be a
hundred percent capacity hospitals one
of xmx is capacity the problem that
there's two hospitals next to each other
each of the excess capacity that's
inefficient it'd be more efficient to
have one hospital one merge hospital
then they just managed a proper amount
of excess capacity and hospitals made
this argument and we basically approved
any household merger that they wanted in
the 2000s well what happened what
happened is the hospitals lied they kept
both hospitals open kept all the empty
beds and just raised prices so
essentially the hospital mergers did not
deliver any of the economies of scale
they promised but did deliver a lot of
the market power we feared so a huge
cause of the increase in medical
spending in the 2000s was these hospital
mergers which essentially took a lot of
the competitive pressure out of the
medical market and didn't really deliver
economies of scale and this is the hard
part about being a regulator most of
what public policy economists do in the
world is regulate all over the world
there are thousands of economists
employed all over the world hundreds of
that tens of thousands whose job it is
to make regulatory decisions of this
nature and they're really hard because
we've drawn nice clean theoretical
models here but we have to know what's
Epsilon you know how much wit what's
epsilon to figure out the effect to
consumers what are the economies of
scale will they actually split those
economies of scale etc so these are
really hard and interesting decisions
now let's go on to the last topic I want
to cover today which is price
competition price competition now the
models we've been discussing so far have
been what we call quantity competition
the United American compete on how many
flights descend and then the demand
curve tells them what they can charge
but in fact in many markets that's not
how firms compete in fact we even
mentioned it
I mentioned about best price offers etc
they don't compete on quantity compete
on price and that's a different model
named after another French economist
portraying a model of Bertrand
competition is the model of price
competition as a model we call
portraying competition this model says
that basically two firms compete over
what price to set and then the quantity
is determined by by the price that
results from that competition so to
compete over quantity to compete over
price and the main curve then tells you
the quantity okay now in this case
what's really striking about Bertrand
competition is that unlike the cournot
model under Bertrand competition two
firms can be enough to get us to the
competitive equilibrium why why do we
only potentially two firms to get the
competitive equilibrium yeah why don't
you explain a little bit more you mean
exactly as long as there's profits to be
made it's like our entry exit decisions
right as long as his profits to be made
I'm gonna come in at a price one penny
below you make one penny less profits
and steal all the business from you so
if there's perfect competition between
firms in a poor Tran sense then you only
need two firms to get to the competitive
equilibrium in theory okay so it's a
very different idea that cournot
competition where you need many many
firms to get close to the competitive
outcome with price competition because
firms are always kind of competing to go
one penny below each other in a market
that's otherwise competitive you could
actually drive the price to competitive
price through essentially you can
actually drive the price down to
marginal cost it's sort of like I talked
about contestable markets and as long as
a profit we made some would enter here
as long as those profits we made someone
or lower their price and that'll keep
happening until price equals marginal
cost
so I'm Bertrand competition you actually
can get close to where at to the
competitive outcome with a small number
of firms now two points to make about
this your first point is well holy [ __ ]
how do i side which one of these to use
you've just taught me you've just spent
you know lecture and half of this fancy
model spent our 37 seconds on this model
how do I know which one to use you
didn't write down any math so I'm gonna
do I'm freaking out okay how do I know
which one to use well the bottom line is
we're not going to ask you do much math
about portraying competition other than
sort of the intuition the competing over
price the more relevant question is how
do you think about the situation's
workwear cournot competition is more
likely and Bertrand competition more
likely so what do you think and what
types of markets unique or no
competition be more likely and what
kinds of markets do you think Bertrand
competition will be more likely yeah
well elasticity is the same so basically
elasticity is gonna have a similar
effect in both it's gonna basically
drive the price down in both okay
because he less does he's higher droves
to mark up for a trend it's gonna its
drive you less to drive it down in both
so it's not a silly about eliciting it's
something about production processes
what type of production processes are
gonna lend themselves to price
competition versus quantity competition
think about this way if I offer a price
what do I have to do that's roughly
speaking right basically if there's long
lags in production I can't do price
competition so if I say I'm gonna
compete people say great I want all your
product I'm like great you could have it
in a year that doesn't work so things
like auto companies are gonna have a
hard time with pure price competition
because if Toyota says okay I'm a dollar
less someone says okay great
we want a million Toyota's tomorrow they
can't do it so things which are capital
intensive lagged production processes
it's gonna be hard to have pure reality
life of course could be some mix of
these but it'll tend more towards
quantity competition because you're
really going to peter --what unicel
because that's sort of you can't just
infinitely supply it whereas other
things like cereal sales where you could
sort of immediately crank up a million
more box of cereal in like a day out of
your production process that will be
more likely to be price calm
things with small production lags then
you'd be more like to that price
competition because if you lower the
price all the sudden you dominate the
market you can meet that demand okay so
essentially we could think about price
competition as being more likely they
small the production lag or maybe the
less capital and it's not really by
capital density because you can have a
capital hence addition you can create
things quickly it's more about
production lags now we're never gonna
ask you to tell us which is right and of
course in reality life somewhere in
between but this just gives you a sense
of kind of when more one type of
competition is more likely than the
other yeah great segue you've jumped
ahead to the last point I want to make
which is imagine you're in a Bertrand
competition world like with cereal
that's a pretty awful world if you're a
producer okay basically that's where
your markups tiny because any time try
to raise the price you get undercut what
can you do well we've already gotten the
answer what you can do you can engage in
product differentiation you can engage
in product differentiation okay so
basically the reason why you're in
Bertrand competition is because you're
selling the same thing once I'm selling
something different I take on the
features of monopolist again
so if I could get sumers to not think of
my good as identical to my competitors
then I can price above marginal cost and
people still buy it the reason Bertrand
competition drives price to marginal
cost because people who used the goods
is identical but if they don't view the
goods identical then I can keep price
above marginal cost okay
and the example of breakfast cereals is
the perfect way to illustrate this so
back around World War two they were
essentially basically like three types
of cereal okay
there was Cheerios there was corn flakes
and Quaker Oats
okay that's basically what cereal was
not very exciting now by the night but
by 1970 there were more than a hundred
and fifty breakfast cereals to choose
from
including some which are variations of
Cheerios in variation of cornflakes in
fact you could all say in some sense all
cereals variation of Shiro's and
cornflakes and oats and then um and
moreover now if you go to store today
you can actually buy generic versions of
brand-name cereals so you can buy OD O's
or marshmallow matey's which are Lucky
Charms or what are they what's the other
one I love buying these big bags you
guys are buy these generic lectrons
marshmallow matey's generic Captain
Crunch is like you know ahoy matey or
something I don't know they got these
generic things which you can buy which
are really just the same so essentially
what you do what companies want to
always do whichever trend competition is
always try to proc differentiate always
try to figure out a way they can create
a market where they can price above
marginal cost okay so for example let's
take General Mills a company that makes
Cheerios okay they're making Cheerios
and then they and then also an OD O's
and stuff started coming along and they
weren't making money what do they do
they created different kinds of Cheerios
like Apple Cinnamon Cheerios General
Mills do not create Apple Cinnamon
Cheerios out of the goodness of their
heart General Mills created Apple
Cinnamon Cheerios because they were
getting killed in the cheerio market and
so they tried to differentiate by having
a new product that on which they could
charge a higher price which was Apple
Cinnamon Cheerios now how do we feel
about this well it's not clear on the
one hand by introducing Apple Cinnamon
Cheerios General Mills was able to push
its price greater than marginal cost and
when as price pushed above marginal cost
quantity sold in the market Falls it
created deadweight loss quantity fell
and that's bad
okay on the other hand Apple Cinnamon
chairs are quite good ok so this
actually ends up being much like our
patent discussion which is essentially
by differentiating they've had two
effects they've lowered consumer surplus
in welfare by pricing about marginal
cost but raised it by shifting out the
demand curve by creating a new good that
people want
yeah that's okay another way stating my
point even if the demand curve razzle
let's say there's a new demand curve for
Apple cinema shows its way out okay
that's great okay but still the fact
that their pricing above marginal cost
means they'll sell fewer than they would
in a competitive market if they had
invented out certain shows and sold on
marginal cost who still be way better
off so the trade-off is essentially how
far out do we shift demand by cratons
new product versus how much you restrict
sales by pricing it above marginal cost
so essentially um now and now what we
have is a market with about five firms
that dominated at about five thousand
brands of cereal okay so it's constant
product differentiation and essentially
this is the trade-off with product
differentiation which is we get reduced
sale we get a deadweight loss because
they're not pricing at marginal cost but
we get new products that people might
like yeah imitation
well actually that's really interesting
it depends on whether that brand loyalty
is based on innovation or blind or blind
faith so it says that this is this is
once again this gets into the deep
interesting issues of industrial
organization you talk about game theory
which is if I can create brand loyalty
by in a way that makes you slightly
better off but keeps you in my brain
forever then that might be worse if I
create in a way that makes you much
better off that might be better so
essentially that's why for example you
may have noticed you may be getting one
or two credit card mailers that's it you
guys are you guys getting inundated with
credit card offers okay it's not because
they love you guys it's because if they
hook you now then you might stick with
that credit card later so try and
exploit trying to get you they're trying
to give you a good deal now to get you
hooked later second charge them closer
to monopoly price later on so
essentially there's a trade-off which is
if that loyalty is based on real
differences in quality that might be
good if it's not it might not be but the
welfare gets very murky it's a good
question other questions okay
these are exciting real world topics
it's more reasons to go on and study
more in economics but let's stop now
we'll come back and we'll start talking
about factor markets on Monday